Hey, welcome to the very last class, the
grand finale.
Today we do the American Empire.
July 1944, this is the Bretton Woods
Hotel in New Hampshire. 40 nations get
together and they discuss
what the post-war peace will look like.
Um everyone knows that Nazi Germany will
eventually be defeated as well as Japan.
So the question now is how does the
world build peace
um and prosperity after such a
devastating uh war. And Americans
propose the Bretton Woods system.
The idea is this. The idea is to
facilitate global trade.
The American currency will become the
reserve currency of the world, meaning
that everyone can use it to trade.
Um now
the term we use for this is exorbitant
privilege.
This is like the power of God because
you're basically turn taking paper
turning into gold, right? That's the
power of God. So how can we ensure the
Americans won't abuse this power? And
the answer is the Americans agree
to create a global financial network as
well as peg
the currency to gold, which means that
the USD is a contract um and at any
point you can choose to exchange US
dollars for gold. And so what America
does is it transports all the gold from
London to Fort Knox.
And that becomes the basis for the new
uh global financial system that we still
have today. And um it is incredibly
successful.
This is the Bank of International
Settlements in Basel, Switzerland and it
is the Bank of Banks. It is the central
bank of central banks. And the idea here
is um Um, need to create a system for
risk man for risk mitigation. So, for
example, if maybe um a country goes
bankrupt, the other countries need to
come in and uh rescue that country's
economy.
Okay? And so, this bank is some of you
never heard of, but it's one of the most
powerful institutions in the world
because it facilitates the entire global
financial economy.
Bretton Woods also created something
called the World Bank,
um which is based in Washington D.C. And
what it does is that um it gives out
loans to third world nations like China.
The IMF, the International Monetary
Fund, coordinates global financial
policy, okay? So,
um
the the the Bank of International
Settlements, the World Bank, the IMF,
among other organizations, now becomes
the global financial system. And
underpinning all of this is the US
dollar as the global reserve
currency.
Okay.
So, um
where did this system come from?
Well, it comes from 1688. Remember, this
is the year that William of Orange of
the Netherlands, he goes to England and
launches something called the Glorious
Revolution, and he takes the throne from
James II. When he goes to England, he
also brings with him Dutch wealth.
Right? Because the Netherlands is now
the most prosperous nation in the world
because of global trade. They have
something called the Dutch um
uh West Indies Company that has
monopolized the spice trade in um
um
East Asia. So, it's the Dutch East East
East Indies Company.
And so, it's extremely wealthy. Now, as
we discussed previously, the Dutch are
Calvinists. So, they that So, they
believe that there's a religious
obligation for them to get wealthy.
Wealth will guarantee their entry into
heaven. But for that to happen, they
need to ensure their wealth is
protected, right? And at this point in
history, the Netherlands is is being
conquered or at war with France, with
Spain, with with a host of of enemies.
So, it's not The money isn't safe in
the Netherlands, so it's being
transferred over to England because
England has a navy that is the most
powerful in the world. It's also an
island, so it's pretty hard to invade.
1694, this wealth becomes a basis of the
Bank of England, which is considered the
second um
oldest central bank in the world, but
it's really the first central bank in
the world. The reason why is
um
this bank, it's a private bank,
but it's guaranteed by Parliament, which
means that the nation-state of England
promises to always pay back the
investors in this bank. So, why does
this happen? It happens because it will
resolve a huge issue throughout human
history. If you're a king, you need
financing to go to war. You often need
to pay for mercenaries.
Um to get this money, you need to
basically borrow from your wealthiest
citizens. The problem with this is as
king, you may not want to pay back that
money after the war or you could get
killed in the war. Okay, so there's
always tremendous risk when you lend
money to the king. The Bank of England
solves this problem because you're not
lending money to the king, you're
lending money to England. And the people
will always have to pay you back. All
right, so maybe
they won't pay you back today, but
they'll have to pay you back sooner or
later, okay? Because it's guaranteed by
Parliament. And this system is extremely
successful. In fact, this system is what
allows England to defeat Napoleon
um in the Napoleonic Wars, okay? In
1815, Napoleon is finally defeated.
Um, so, as we discussed previously,
Napoleon, he is a military genius, and
he conquers most of Europe, and he
defeats England many, many times. But,
because of the Bank of England,
Napole- the the English have infinite
financing. So, the British are always
financing wars against Napoleon until he
is finally defeated, and this
establishes
the British Empire, okay? So, after the
defeat of Napoleon and France, uh
Britain becomes the global hegemon.
And the Bank of England now becomes an
imperial bank, and the power of this is
um before, when you go when you go and
conquer um a um a country or nation,
you're always afraid of rebellion.
Right? You're always afraid of local
elite getting getting together and
overthrowing you. But, the Bank of
England solves this problem. Why? It
solves this problem because now the
local elite can take their corrupt
earnings and put it in the Bank of
England.
All right? So, now the elite have an
incentive to work with the British to
maintain their empire, and that's how
Britain was able to build the world's
first truly global empire and able to
maintain such harmony and stability
within the empire for such a long time,
okay? The secret was international
finance
as embodied by the Bank of England,
okay? So, let's summarize
the history of central banking, okay?
It's complicated, but we need to
understand this history if you
understand today's world. First
important idea is that Dutch Calvinists,
um they have a religious obsession with
storing wealth, okay? Remember, we
discussed this, right? The Protestant
religion
demands that you get rich.
The Parliament of England guarantees
this wealth, it does give in England
infinite financing for wars. This is
important because if Parliament is
willing to guarantee financing,
um not only can it use all this wealth
stored in the Bank of England, but it
can also generate new wealth from
investors overseas as well, okay? Third
idea,
this financing, if it financing, allows
Britain to defeat Napoleon.
Fourth, the Bank of England stores
wealth of corrupt local elites, allowing
for stability and and harmony within the
within the empire. Now, this is
important. What will happen next is
America will emulate this model and
create something called the Federal
Reserve in the year 1914. So, the idea
of the Federal Reserve is you have all
these provincial banks around America.
They get together and decide
um that we as private banks will
convince the government, the Congress,
to give us the power to print money.
How do you print money? You issue loans,
okay? When you issue loans, you're just
basically
putting money into the system, okay? So,
um in 1914, they developed the Federal
Reserve system.
And after World War
uh two, America is now able to export
this Federal Reserve system all around
the world by creating independent
central banks in each nation and having
these central banks work together to
create more wealth for the investors.
So, there's something really important
you have to understand. Nation-states
compete against each other, but
independent central states,
all these nation-states work together.
Because that way, it's easier for them
to generate wealth for their investors,
okay? To grow capital, private central
banks coordinate rather than compete.
They're parasites that feed off the
nation-state. Okay? So, this is a really
important idea that no one understands.
The nation-state is responsible for
protecting this wealth,
and these central banks can use the
resources of the nation-state to feed
its capital growth, okay? And this is
the modern financial system that we have
today. The central banks basically rule
the world.
All right?
Okay. So, um this is Carroll Quigley,
and he wrote a book called Tragedy and
Hope, which I highly recommend. He was a
Georgetown professor. He was um Bill
Clinton's favorite professor at
Georgetown. And um in this book, he
explains how this financial system
works, okay? So, let's read it very
carefully.
And this is And he's talking about the
1920s. After World War I, the powers of
financial capitalism had another
far-reaching aim, nothing less than to
create a world system of financial
control in private hands able to
dominate the political system of each
country and the economy of the world as
a whole. This system was to be
controlled in a feudalist fashion by the
central banks of the world acting in
concert by secret agreements arrived at
in frequent private meetings and
conferences. The apex of the system was
to be the Bank of International
Settlements in Basel, Switzerland, a
private bank owned and controlled by the
world's central banks, which were
themselves private corporations. Each
central bank, in the hands of men like
Montagu Norman of the Bank of England,
Benjamin Strong of the New York Federal
Reserve, Charles Rist of the Bank of
France, and Hjalmar Schacht of the
Reichsbank, sought to dominate its
government by its ability to control
treasury loans, to manipulate foreign
exchanges, to influence the level of
economic activity in the country, and to
influence cooperative politicians by
subsequent economic rewards in the
business world. Okay? So, in today's
world, it's the central banks acting in
concert that dictate financial,
economic, and political policy all
around the world.
All right.
So, how can we understand
um central banks? Well, the main
function of central banks is to uh
control the money supply.
Okay? So, money is just a concept. It's
an idea. It's something that we just
made up.
And the way that central bank controls
money is by controlling its scarcity,
which creates the illusion that it's
valuable. Okay? Also, you're forced to
use money to buy things as well as pay
taxes, take out loans. All right? Um and
they control the interest rate, which is
the cost of borrowing money. So, another
way of saying this is
one mechanism the central bank has to
control the economy is by lowering or by
lowering or increasing interest rates.
With lower interest rate, it's just
easier to be able to borrow money,
right? So, you can go buy a house or buy
a car. They increase the um interest
rate, it's more expensive, so people
will spend less money. So, through that
mechanism, they're able to control the
supply of money in the system.
All right?
All right. So, how do we understand what
central bankers are? Well, I'll give you
three possible metaphors, okay? And I
think these are
legitimate. Central bankers are the
ultimate priests. They must control the
flow of money to maintain the illusion
that money is God. In this way, they are
the new
Catholic Church, okay? Remember the
Catholic Church in medieval Europe
was the dominant power. It was uh beyond
nations. Um it was it represented God on
Earth. Well, that's what central bankers
are today. But also,
you can think of central bankers as the
game masters. They must control the flow
of money to motivate people to play the
game. As we discussed when we discussed
the Americans, today we live not in a
civil civilization, but in a game where
we're all individual players trying to
make as much money as possible. And
central central central bankers are the
ones who control the rules of this game.
Last metaphor is central bankers are
drug pushers. To expand their dominance,
they offer easy money, and once a
country is addicted or bankrupt, they
hijack the financial system, which means
to privatize or make independent the
central bank, okay? So, how do central
bankers work? Well, let's let let let's
let's do an experiment, okay? Let's
let's use a thought experiment. Let's
just say I'm a central bank
and you and I'm trying to get you to
become addicted to my power, right? So,
what I do is this. I say to you, "Hey,
here's $10,000."
And you're like, "Okay, and what do you
want for $10,000?" And I'm like,
"Nothing. Just go enjoy yourself." So,
you So, you take that $10,000 and you go
uh go on vacation to Hawaii.
You live in a five-star hotel. You're
really happy. You come back and you say,
"That was great. Can I get more money?"
And I'm like, "Here. Here's a million
dollars. Go and enjoy yourself." And
you're like, "What do you want for it?"
And I'm like, "Nothing. Just go enjoy
yourself." So, you go, but this time
you're smarter. You're like, "No, no,
no, no, no. This money is limited. I
need to go invest it
if I want to generate more money, okay?
Otherwise, I have to I have to go back
to the bank and get more money."
So, you start doing you start um opening
businesses. You invest in restaurants
and ski resorts. Who knows, okay? But
you you have all these investments. The
problem is you really don't know what
you're doing.
And you make these bad investments. And
eventually, what you recognize is you're
in debt now. You had a million dollars,
but now you owe 10 million dollars. So,
you come back to the bank and you say,
"Listen, I need 10 million dollars." And
I'm like, "Fine, but now you have to
give me your soul."
And you're like, you're just stuck,
okay? That's how central banks work. I
like I I I know this sounds terrible,
but that's really how they work in the
world. All right? So, now I'll give you
examples.
All right.
So, what central banks do is they have
the power of God. They're alchemists,
basically, because they can take paper
uh which we know is worthless and turn
it into gold, which is what everyone
wants.
Um now, something to remember, and this
is really important, is that throughout
history, whenever there's a major power,
there's always a rising power that
challenges it. So, in our world today,
there's no nation state that can
challenge the power of the central
banks. But, there are these technology
companies that are arising that are
trying to displace them from Gotham,
okay? So,
um
Bitcoin is something they've invented.
It is the American military's fail-safe
system in case American government
defaults on the debt and the US dollar
loses its reserve currency status. So,
Bitcoin has been controlled by the
American military along with certain
technology companies, and they're trying
to displace the USD.
All right? So, so there's a conflict
going on here.
All right. Also,
artificial intelligence will be used to
create the illusion of God. Right? Why
is there so much investment interest in
artificial intelligence? Because, even
though it doesn't really work that well,
it can trick people into believing it is
God, that it is omniscient, that it is
always right, that it is the ultimate
authority.
Last example,
sorry. Last example is social media,
video games, and porn are the drug of
the 21st
century, okay? So, in other words, these
technology companies, they're really in
the process of of creating a matrix in
which we just live in a simulation, and
we're all slaves to the simulation.
Okay? So,
um
um this is something that we need to
think about, how the central banks are
in power, but there's always powers that
are arising and which will challenge the
power of the central banks.
Okay.
So, how do we get this system?
Um go back to year 1950,
1960. The world is divided into two,
right? It's divided between the
capitalist West and the communist East.
Now, this is ultimately a war of
ideology. It's really a question of
which system, capitalism or communism,
is better for humanity. Well, well, we
don't know the answer to that question,
but we do know the elite prefer
capitalism, because capitalism gives
them more power, gives them more wealth.
So, the elites both in China and the
Soviet Union, they basically give up,
okay? In 1991, the Soviet Union
basically unconditionally surrenders.
And this creates the complete dominance
of the American system, the Pax
Americana.
Um so, once America has domination, it
now can spread its system throughout the
world. This is Karl Popper, and he wrote
a book called The Open Society. And in
it, he questions
um grand ideologies because he believes
that it's these grand ideologies like
communism and fascism that destroyed the
world and which have led to World War
II. He hates Plato. He hates Marx. He
hates Hegel. He thinks these are the
three totalitarian philosophers in human
history. And so, what he proposes is
that the height of civilization is the
Anglo-American civilization. Okay? The
Germans and the Russians are bad because
they are racists, because they are
nationalistic, because they are grand in
their vision. They're always trying to
transform humans to shapes and um things
that hum- that that are that are
anti-human. But the Americans and the
British, they are practical. They are
utilitarian. They are They believe in
evolution, okay? And he And that's what
Karl And so, Karl Popper believes the
Anglo-American civilization is really
the height of human civilization.
But there's actually another way to
understand the Pax Americana. And so,
the idea is from World War II, we we
transfer the Pax Americana. And there
are major differences, right? So, World
War II was about the nation-state. That
was the main constituent body of World
War II. In the Pax Americana, what
matters is the international rules-based
order, which includes central banks, but
also includes United Nations, right? Um
World War II was about merca-
mercantilism. Mercantilism is that you
only trade within your sovereignty,
okay? You only trade with your colonies.
But Pax Americana argues for global free
trade. Global free trade will lead to
prosperity in the world. World War II
argues for unit will and Pax Americana
argues for consumerism. Okay? The unit
will is the idea that we must be a
whole, that the the constituent parts
together are less than the whole, okay?
Consumerism is just individuals should
just go and spend money and enjoy the
life and don't worry about big problems
like the nation-state um and if history,
these ideas.
All right.
In other words, what's happened in our
world is the world's gone from one that
focus on civilization to a game. In in a
civilization, people are citizens who
who sacrifice themselves in order to
obtain glory, okay? So, think of
Achilles.
Right? Achilles went to Troy because he
was in competition among the his his
other Greeks to
uh seek eternal glory, okay?
But in the game, we're all individual
players who are trying to make as much
money as possible. Now, in theory,
you're taught that, okay, the best way
to do that is to work hard, be smart, be
talented, create something innovative,
right? But in reality, the best way to
to make money is by cheating, okay? What
what what is cheating? Cheating is
basically creating a monopoly.
And then you're forced and everyone else
is forced to uh pay as much as you want,
okay? So, John Rockefeller,
um Bill Gates, these were all
monopolists and and they were the
wealthiest people in human history,
okay?
All right. So,
um after
uh World War II, America is the
only major industrial nation left
standing. And America used the
opportunity to rebuild both its economy
as well as the global economy. And it
does so
by
trans- transferring its wartime economy
into a peacetime economy. Okay, in a
wartime economy, you're manufacturing
goods
at mass, right? When a peacetime
economy, you're also doing that. The
problem though is now that you have
peace,
who's going to buy these products? So,
what What America did was it basically
said to Europe,
"We'll make these products, these
manufactured goods, these cars, and you
will buy them." Europe's like, "We have
no money." And America's like, "Don't
worry about it. We're lending you the
money, okay?"
And so, this worked out really well for
America. If you were a white high school
graduate
male in America in the 1950s, '60s,
'70s, you had the best life. You lived
better than the nobility of Rome, okay?
This is just a guy. He could be a
salesperson. He could be a clerk. He
could be a factory worker. But he had a
car. In fact, he probably had two cars.
He had his own house. His wife didn't
have to work. And he could send his
three kids to college.
Also, they could take one or two
vacations a year to Europe. It was
really the best life. And that's what
the Pax Americana created, okay?
Prosperity and peace for the American
middle class.
But the problem is that over time, the
Germans start to catch up. The Germans
uh were destroyed in World War II. So,
they were incentivized to work together,
to work hard to rebuild their uh
civilization. And German manufacturing
became famous throughout the world, as
did Japanese manufacturing, okay? So,
now what's happening is because of the
superiority of German and Japanese
manufactured goods, America was
transiting transiting from a creditor
nation where everyone owed it money to a
debtor nation where its consumers were
buying things that they They really
afford from overseas, okay?
And again,
America could do so because America had
the US dollar as the reserve currency.
Um
1961,
Dwight Eisenhower is retiring from the
presidency and he says to the American
people,
um I know we are at war
with the Soviet Union, it's a cold war,
but we don't have any real enemies.
Our enemies are all internal.
There is currently in play something
called the military-industrial complex.
They employ millions of people,
they manufacture weapons, and they're
intent on war. They are our true enemy.
If we allow the military-industrial
complex to hijack the American political
system,
then we'll be caught then we'll be
constantly fighting these useless wars
that will bankrupt our nation. Be aware.
This is our greatest threat to our
nation in our history.
Okay? This is his farewell address.
The potential for the disastrous rise of
misplaced powers exist and will persist.
We must never let the weight of this
combination endanger our liberties or
democratic processes, okay? He's talking
about the military-industrial complex.
And it proved present and prophetic
because after he after he retired,
America will start engaging in wars
around the world that it could neither
afford nor could it fight properly and
it bankrupted America. Most famous
example is the Vietnam War.
Okay? Uh where America lost about 50,000
soldiers and killed millions and
millions of Vietnamese civilians. It was
uh
pointless,
brutal war that almost bankrupted
America. And it almost caused a civil
war in America.
Right?
Um at this time, America was also
competing in with the Soviet Union in
the space race.
Right? So in in 1969, America sent
um a man to the moon. And this is a real
picture, okay? Now, some of you might be
like Some of you who might be conspiracy
theorists, okay, not me, but some of you
might be conspiracy theorists say, "Wait
a minute here. Why is the lighting
perfect on the moon, right? And why are
there no stars in this in space? And why
is this flag uh floating around, okay?"
Conspiracy theorists would would ask
these questions. I don't ask these
questions because I'm not a conspiracy
theorist.
Just just so we're completely sure,
okay? Also, at this time,
Lyndon B. Johnson
announced the Great Society, which was
just a fantastic social program to
ensure that each and every American had
an opportunity at the American dream,
okay? So, you had um
um free healthcare for the elderly. You
had programs like Head Start. It was
fantastic, but it's also really, really
expensive. So,
if you are
um a nation like France, you're like,
"You know what? America is what sending
people to the moon.
Um it's fighting all these pointless
wars. It's um
um building all these great social
programs for its population. Does
America have the money to do this?"
In other words, is it possible that the
US currency, the US dollar, is no longer
able to repay its obligations?
That's why France, under Charles de
Gaulle, sent warships to America in the
mid-60s to repatriate its gold. It's
afraid that America will uh go bankrupt.
And this proved very, very wise.
And at this And when when after France
did this, there's now this fear among
Americans that every nation will do
this. And then every every nation did
this, America will go bankrupt, right?
That's why
in the year 1971, Richard Nixon
announces
the US dollar will no longer be tied to
gold, which means that you can't use US
dollars to buy gold anymore.
Which means what? Which means the US
dollar is based on nothing. The value of
the US dollar is now based primarily
primarily on people's faith in its
value.
Okay?
So, this leads to a lot of problems like
inflation and oil shock. So, to solve
this problem,
in 1973, Nixon signed an agreement with
Saudi Arabia. Basically, the agreement
is that from now on, Saudi Arabia, which
is the world's largest oil exporter,
will only take payments in US dollars.
And whatever savings that Saudi Arabia
has
will be invested in US Treasuries. Okay?
So, this is what we call the
petrodollar.
And the idea here is now the value of
the US dollar is tied to the value of
oil, okay?
You can always exchange US dollars for
oil.
But then, Nixon did something that was
all that was extremely clever.
He went to China, okay? So, for the
longest time, China and the United
States were in a Cold War. Americans
basically isolated China. So, in 1972,
Nixon visited Mao Zedong.
Why?
The answer is very simple. Because he
needed more consumers to buy US dollars.
Does that make sense? He needed people
to want US dollars. He needed to create
a US dollar addiction.
And to do this,
what did America do? America gave China
everything.
America started to ship its factories
overseas to China.
America gave all its expertise and
technology to China. America started to
to educate the Chinese elite. And what's
really important is
American defense companies started to
give military secret technology to
China, okay? Now, I know that the United
States, people believe that China stole
this technology. China did not to steal
this technology because America gave it
to China for free, okay?
Why would it Why would Why would America
do this? To create dependence on
America. Because once a dependence is
created, then Chinese people want US
dollars, okay? The intention has always
been to create a market for US dollars
in order to prop up the uh
US currency, okay? Does that make sense?
So, Saudi Arabia uh gave its oil to the
United States, and China gave its labor,
okay? Its most precious commodity to the
United States exchange for US dollars.
All right. So, why is this important?
Let's look at the case of Japan. The
year is 1985, okay?
And this is something called the Plaza
Accord.
The Plaza Accord was between the central
bankers um and the finance ministries of
different nations, but probably between
the United States and Japan. Japan at
this point was an export powerhouse. It
was the second largest economy in the
world. Um high savings rate. Uh people
really didn't want to buy American
goods, but but Americans loved Japanese
goods, okay? So, it was creating this
trade imbalance. And Japan was growing
and becoming an economic powerhouse.
So, America said to Japan, "Listen,
you guys need to restructure your
economy because your consumers aren't
spending any money. This creates trade
imbalance, and ultimately this will lead
to structural problems in Japan. So,
what we're going to do is we will
revalue
the Japanese currency. We will
appreciate it with We will appreciate it
against the US dollar, okay? So, as
Japanese um consumers, you're able to
buy more from the United States." Now,
Japanese
uh economists thought this was a
terrible idea,
but because America has military bases
in Japan, Japan didn't really have a
choice in the matter, right? And so,
this created
um the Japanese
uh,
explosion of wealth, okay? So, they were
in my Rockefeller
um, Plaza in New York City and this
created uh, a fear of Japan in uh, in
the United States. So, to show you to
demonstrate you to you how ridiculous
the situation was,
in the year 1990, uh, in Kyoto, the
Imperial Grounds, okay? I'm I'm I'm not
talking about the city of Kyoto. I'm
talking about the Imperial Grounds in
Kyoto, okay? That land by itself was
worth more than Canada as a country. You
could You could sell the the Imperial
Grounds of Kyoto and go buy Canada for
yourself, okay? That's how ridiculous
the situation was in Japan because of
the appreciation of the yen. Cheap money
flooded into the nation of Japan and so
people were speculating on real estate
and the stock market, okay? Which led to
ultimately economic collapse in Japan.
So, as you can see, um, from the '60s up
until about the '90s, Japanese growth
was pretty strong. But, after the Plaza
Accord, you saw a steep drop, okay? The
Plaza Accord, by pushing the yen, by
giving Japanese easy money, it destroyed
the Japanese economy.
All right? So, remember this.
If you want to nuke an economy in you
want to destroy an economy in a nation,
give them easy money.
All right? If I want to destroy you as a
person, I'm going to give you a million
dollars because you're going to take
that million dollars and do stupid
things with it, okay?
Can you clarify the easy money?
Oh, okay. Yeah.
Um, what does easy money mean? Easy
money just means that you think it's
free.
You don't have to You have to work for
it. You don't have to um, earn it, okay?
And the idea of easy money is central
banks have the power to print money.
So, if you come to me and I'm bank,
actually just give you a million dollars
and you take it.
That's easy money, right?
Okay? That's the idea, okay? So, you
don't understand this. I It's a hard
concept to understand, but banks have
that power. They can just put money out
of nothing.
Okay? And And this is what we call easy
money.
And what this leads to is a disaster.
Okay? So, let's go over the list of how
easy money destroys nations. First is
that it turns manufacturers into
financial speculators. The reason why is
maybe your car company, okay? And before
you make you you you making good money
uh making cars and selling them to
Americans.
But if the economy is is blowing up, the
stock market is increasing, the real
estate market is increasing, you're
actually better off taking all your
savings, your investments, and put it
into the stock market.
Right? Because you you got better
returns. And as a corporation, you have
to guarantee better returns for your
investors, okay?
It makes people lazy, selfish, and
greedy. That's That's easy to
understand, right? If someone just give
you a million dollars, you would not
want to work or study ever again in your
life.
Um you create too much debt too quickly.
You create financial bubbles, corruption
between uh the politicians and the
financial elite. You create massive
inequality. Right? Because it's usually
the wealthy who most benefit from this
wealth generation. Uh you will increase
unemployment and bankruptcies. And the
last thing, this is really important, is
because all all this surge in
um
um in prices, you price out young people
and you destroy the nation's future. You
look at the birth rate in Japan. It's
about one, okay? And the reason why is
Japanese young people do not see a
future for themselves. Houses are too
expensive. The
um
um jobs don't pay that well, okay?
Um any questions before before I
continue?
I- I- I- Is this fair?
Okay.
All right. Let's continue.
But it's not just Japan. It's also the
United States 1997 Asian financial
crisis. Remember, uh this is when South
Korea, Thailand, Indonesia um their
currencies were under attack.
And because your currencies were under
attack, um they became devalued. The
problem with this is
um
before this, Thailand, Indonesia, and
South Korea had access to easy money
provided by central banks. And so they
so they could afford to buy things
overseas, invest things overseas. They
could but once the value was was de-
once the currency was devalued,
they now went bankrupt, okay?
And as a result, the National
Monetary Monetary Fund was able to step
in and privatize the central banks.
So that's the playbook.
All right.
1989 is important because that's when
the Berlin Wall fell and the Soviet
Union and communism came to an end. Now
it's a Pax Americana, okay? And in the
Pax Americana, the system is
America would ship its manufacturing
overseas. Remember, manufacturing was a
source of middle-class wealth
generation. Now it's shipping all all
its manufacturing overseas to focus on
financialization.
All right. So the idea is that Wall
Street would take all its money, all
this wealth being generated overseas,
and then
take it back to America and use it to
um invest in America to basically engage
in financial games.
Okay? Does that make sense? So in other
words, before America was manufacturing
things like cars and and washing
machines. Now America is just gambling,
okay? The entire economy is is based on
gambling anymore. And this will lead to
something called the 2008 Great
Financial Crisis where the global
economy collapses, basically.
Um 2001, 9/11,
um
the World Trade Center, right? Uh the
terrorist attacks. Again, I'm not a
conspiracy theorist, so I'm not going to
go into the conspiracies behind this.
But it lead it led to something called
the war on terror where America, for no
particular reason, went to Iraq, Syria,
Libya, and destroyed
these countries. Now, if you're a
conspiracy theorist, you would say,
"Well, they destroyed these countries
because these countries didn't have
central banks." All right? So, that's
what some people say. I would not say
that. I'm not a conspiracy theorist.
2008 is the great financial crisis. Why
did it happen? It happened because
America had become a gambling economy.
And so, it had to take money and invest
it. The problem, though, is there's too
much money flowing into America and
there's not enough good investments. So,
what Washington did was it started to
invest in really bad investments. It was
encouraging people with no money to go
and buy out buy like five houses, okay?
And eventually, they would they would
have to default. And when they default,
it would create a cascading effect where
the entire global economy would
collapse. And that's what the what's
what was the 2008 great financial
crisis. To solve this problem, what
America did was
print money, okay? Look at this, guys.
Up until the year 1980, America had a
about a trillion dollars in debt.
Okay? America was founded in 1776. By
the year 1980, about 20 years later, it
had a trillion dollars in debt. Today,
it has now 37 trillion dollars in debt,
okay? This is all money printing.
Starting about 2008, boom! You you see
this steep curve going all the way up.
All right?
Um the economy in America right now is
really screwed up. The reason why is
the stock market is is worth twice as
much as the real economy.
Okay? That makes no sense at all.
The total value of the US economy is
half of that of the stock market, okay?
So, this shows you that right now
America is living in a fantasy. It's a
make-believe economy.
Um
Um the other problem is this massive
wealth inequality, okay? So, as you can
see,
um the wealth wealthy people are pretty
wealthy. But but by 2000
um but but but by 1980, the time of
Reagan, it shoots all the way up, okay?
So, you have this massive wealth
inequality being
um
um created in the United States. The
This also shows you
how wealthy the top 0.01%
are relative to everyone else, okay? So,
the main beneficiaries of all these
reforms of this financialization has
been the ultra-wealthy in America.
Um at the same time, if you're an
average American, all you're seeing is
your debt go up, okay? Your debt has
gone way up. So, you can make the
argument that the system is designed to
exploit the middle class
by forcing them into debt so as to to
enrich the wealthy's investments, okay?
That's the American system. And in fact,
you can argue the global system. So,
2008, the global economic collapses. So,
what happens, okay? I believe this is
what happened. I don't think this is a
conspiracy theory. The central banks
basically encouraged the Chinese central
bank to start printing money.
Right? And this is important because
when you start printing money and you
invest in real estate, you need
resources. You need to buy resources
from Australia, from Brazil. And this is
what saves the global economy. And this
all looks very impressive, guys. Like I
know when you go outside and you see all
these big buildings and um fancy
um
railways, it's all very impressive. But
remember, okay? This is really
important.
Behind the veneer of this prosperity are
three things. Massive debt, right? This
is money that's being printed. So,
someone has to pay this off. You guys.
Not not the current people, but you guys
or your grandchildren or your
great-grandchildren, okay? But someone
has to pay off this debt. That's number
one. Number two is this has created
massive inequality
in China.
Right? So, the rich are filthy rich and
the poor aren't that much better off.
The third problem, this is really
important, is it's created a lot of
political corruption. All right? So,
behind all this veneer are corruption,
inequality, and debt.
And this is what
Okay?
So, a really important lesson for you
guys to understand the Chinese
relationship with America is this.
There's this very very famous quote by
Charles Baudelaire who said, "The
greatest trick the devil ever pulled was
convincing the world he didn't exist."
Okay? Well, I'm I'm going to I'm going
to paraphrase him, okay? I'm And And
this is what I think is the relationship
between America and China. The greatest
trick America played was convincing
China it could be rich.
All right? This is no different from
1985, the Plaza Accords, when America
basically encouraged the Japanese to
increase the value of their yen, which
led to economic collapse. Well,
but when when Americans encouraged the
Chinese to print money in about 2008 and
about
um 2015,
it basically created conditions for
China's uh economic collapse, okay?
All right. This is what led to the rise
of this man, our dear fearless leader,
okay?
Um
I believe his intentions are good. I
think he wants to save China from this
global financial capitalist system. He
needs to maintain China's independence
and sovereignty. He's fighting very hard
to
um save the Chinese nation.
Okay? That's what I believe. Um and
So, you can make the argument that
what's happening today in China is no
different from the Opium Wars. Remember,
Britain
um created an opium
epidemic in China in order to enslave
the Chinese economy to the global
financial system.
Right? That's That's the Opium Wars.
Well, the same is happening today where
the Americans are basically
created, uh,
Chinese dependency on US dollars. Right?
What's the Chinese dream? The Chinese
dream is work hard,
get into a good school,
get rich,
move your money and your children to the
United States. That's the Chinese dream.
All right? And if that's a dream, then
eventually
this civilization won't last very long.
Am I wrong?
Is that not Is that not the Chinese
dream?
All right.
All right. So, now you have the COVID,
uh, crisis where China's locked down for
3 years.
Now, I'm not a conspiracy theorist,
okay?
But you can make the argument that
some of this was intentional in order to
implode the Chinese economy. Why?
Because Chinese economy had become a
system of transferring wealth from China
to the United States. So, by imploding
the economy, you're stopping this
drainage, okay?
All right. This also led to the rise of
this man, Vladimir Putin, who is very
much like Joseph Stalin. He understands
the grand picture. He understands
strategy, grand strategy. He understands
that now it's time to strike. Why?
Because America has created this crazy
fantastical system, right? Where there's
a hierarchy of prices.
In the American system, the Pax
Americana,
main
resources are the least valuable, okay?
The basis of the resources, right? Which
is what Russia has a lot of.
Up next in this pyramid is
manufacturing, which is what China does.
Then up next is knowledge economy, so
professionals, and that's what Europe
and America does really well, okay? And
at the very top of this pyramid are the
financiers, finance.
And that's what Wall Street dominates,
okay? So, this is the pyramid of the
world that we live in. What Putin said
is this. What Putin said is,
"You know what? If I can control the
world's resources, the oil, the food,
then I can invert this pyramid so that
resource resource at the top." And
that's why you uh Russia invaded
Ukraine. Because if Russia were able to
dominate Ukraine,
Russia and Ukraine together would
control 1/3
1/3 of the world's carbohydrates.
Without Russian food,
Africa and the Middle East would both
starve to death.
Okay?
And so, that is the rationale for
Putin's invasion of Ukraine. He's a
genius. He understands this fundamental
weakness in the American system. Okay?
If you're able to control the resources,
you are able to strangle this financial
system.
Okay? So, by invading Ukraine, Putin
shows that America is a paper tiger.
Faith in the USD rests on the aura of
American military's invulnerability and
invincibility. This now forces the
Americans to invade Iran. Okay, does
that make sense to you guys? The logic
here is very simple.
Why does Saudi Arabia buy US dollars
even though they know it's not it's not
worth anything? Why why does Japan buy
US dollars? Why does Germany? The answer
is, they're afraid that if they don't
buy US dollars, America will come and
invade them. Okay? They have no choice
in the matter. But now that Putin has
shown that, actually, you know what? The
American military is not as strong as
you think it is, the American military
now has no choice but to prove it is as
strong as people believe. It needs to
restore faith in this in the military in
order to restore faith in the US dollar.
Okay, does that make sense?
That's why
the American military has no choice in
the matter but to invade
Iran, okay? Why? Because if they're able
to invade Iran, they're able to control
the entire flow of Middle East oil.
Also,
they're able to control the act of trade
throughout the world, okay? Iran is
really the center of the world in terms
of global trade.
So, these two factors mean that America
needs to eventually invade Iran.
All right.
Once it invades Iran, it creates a huge
problem for China and Japan and South
Korea. Why? Because guess what? These
three nations gets most of this oil from
the Middle East, right? Japan imports
roughly 89% of its oil from the Middle
East. And guess what, guys?
Japan is the largest buyer of US
dollars.
So, if Japan ever says, "You know what?
Screw this. We're not buying US
dollars." the American economy goes
bankrupt.
So, when you invade Iran, you control
the oil supply, you control the entire
Japanese economy. You can charge
whatever price you want
for oil.
All right.
This explains the Israel-Palestine
conflict. Because America just can't
go invade Iran for no reason. It needs a
pretext. The perfect pretext is
Israel comes to conflict with Iran, Iran
attacks Israel, United States must now
defend Israel because Israel is its
ally.
Right? Does that make sense? So, America
needs a scapegoat. That scapegoat is
Israel. That explains why there's so
much conflict right now in the Middle
East.
Look at this map, okay?
This is Iran. It's surrounded by
American bases. You have 14,000 troops
in in Afghanistan. You got like
thousands more
over here, okay? Iran Iran is
surrounded. It seems to me that America
has been preparing to invade Iran for
the past 20 years and is just looking
for the perfect opportunity.
All right. Problem though is that Iran
is not an adversary that America can
defeat. The reason why is its geography
of Iran. Look at this.
In 2003, America went to Iraq and
destroyed Iraq. Why? Iraq's a desert.
It's flat plains.
America has bombs. It has It has fighter
planes, right? It's pretty easy to
destroy a desert. But I I ran Iran is
all mountains. These fighter planes
do no good against mountains. You can't
bomb a mountain into submission.
Okay? So, if America were to invade
Iran,
there's little cha- very little chance
that
um America would win this war.
In fact, it may be the end of the
American empire.
And Putin has a plan, okay? Putin is a
genius. He knows exactly what will
happen. So, Putin is preparing for this
possible invasion
um of Iran.
So, this is a really important picture.
Putin signed an agreement with Kim
Jong-un. The agreement is a mutual
defense pact, which means that
if North Korea is ever if ever attacked,
Putin will come to his aid.
All right? Now, why would Putin do this?
This is really strange.
The answer is this. The answer is
if America attacks Iran,
he needs to throw America off balance by
creating a conflict somewhere else. The
best place to create a conflict would be
Southeast Asia, right? Now, you would
think we don't want it here.
Putin and China are best friends.
If America invades Iran,
then China may invade Taiwan.
But, I've already told you this.
China is dependent on the American
economy, so I do not believe this will
happen.
Okay? And Putin is fairly certain this
won't happen either.
That's why he's He's now best friends
with Kim Jong-un. Because Kim Jong-un,
if he were to
menace South Korea
that would throw
the American military off balance.
Because now there's war on three fronts,
Ukraine,
South North Korea, and Iran, okay?
That's the grand strategy of Putin. This
is his
trump card.
Okay, does that make sense?
All right.
Now,
what I'm saying here is this, I'm saying
like I know there's a lot of conflict
now between China and America, there's a
trade war going on.
Um but I think this will pass. I think
there'll be a rapprochement between
China and America because both economies
are dependent on each other.
Right? So, I think this friendship
between Putin and China won't last very
long.
Um there's also really a lot of
geopolitical reasons why this friendship
won't last very long, right? Because
China and Russia have a lot of
geopolitical conflicts, right? They
share a border, they're trying to vie
for influence in the uh in Central Asia.
There's lots of reasons why in the long
term China and and Russia will
eventually have to break apart. Which
means that Putin now sees his best
friend could be Germany, okay? This is a
this this these I think are going to be
the two big geopol- geopolitical
surprises next 5 years. First of all,
America and China will become best
friends, or not best friends, but
they'll have a rapprochement. And then
Germany and Russia will have a
rapprochement.
Okay?
All right.
So,
um
Donald Trump, President of the United
States,
he wants a third term, okay? He's
creating he uh everything he's doing
right now is because he wants to be king
of the United States. He wants a third
term. Okay, for a variety of reasons,
okay? I I I won't go into many reasons,
okay? But he's that narcissistic.
Um he has to he has to solve a problem.
This problem is
the national debt, right? It's at $37
trillion. You can't pay this off. You
can never pay this off. But the theory
is this, the theory is like as long as
you are the greatest military in the
world, as long as you can go invade
everyone, you don't have to pay this
off. You can you can you can constantly
increase this debt, okay? That's the
theory.
Um this explains the US-China trade war.
Everything that we're seeing today is
because Donald Trump needs to come to an
agreement with China for a variety of
reasons. Okay, the first reason is uh
Trump wants to invade Iran, and so he
needs to be on good terms with China,
okay? Another reason is he needs people
to buy US dollars,
right? And right now there's a lot of
financial repression in China, meaning
that you can't convert uh Chinese
currency into US currency.
Um American investors aren't allowed to
come to China and buy up um Chi- the
Chinese financial system. Trump wants
China to open up. China Trump needs to
create more interdependency between
China and the United States, okay? And
that's why
for Trump, Chinese citizens and students
in America is the ultimate leverage
point in negotiations. Ask yourself why
this is happening. Why is it that your
visas are being threatened? You want to
go to the United States and spend a lot
of money to get American education, but
Trump is saying, "No, no, no, we could
take away your visa."
Why is this happening? It's all part of
of negotiation, okay? There's no way
that America will shut out Chinese
students because America needs that it
needs that money, okay? Well, without
without Chinese spending
money in America, without Chinese
wanting to purchase US dollars, the
American economy will collapse. So,
there's no way that
America will close its boar its door to
Chinese students. But it needs China to
open up its economy furthermore to
create more interdependency to save the
US dollar, okay?
All right.
So,
where am I getting these ideas? Like
like am I just making this stuff up?
Um, so
in this class what you're taught is that
history tends to repeat itself. And by
studying history meticulously and
thoroughly, we can gain insight into the
future. So, what I want to show you now
is there's a direct analogy between
what's happening today and what happened
in Greece um, in about 400 BC, okay?
This is um, Thucydides and he wrote a
very famous book called The History of
the Peloponnesian War, which is what we
discussed last semester. Now, the
Peloponnesian War is a war between
Athens and Sparta for hegemony it um, on
the Greek mainland. Okay?
Um, so in 480
Athens and Sparta were best friends.
They fought against Persia, which was
invading the Greek mainland. And at the
Battle of Salamis, the Athenians
basically destroyed the Persian navy and
the Persians were forced to retreat.
But, there's always a threat that Persia
over here would would come back and
invade uh, Athens and Sparta, okay?
As well, throughout the Aegean Sea are
Greek islands and colonies that are
afraid of Persian hegemony. So, after
the defeat of the Persians the Athenians
got together with these colonies and
they created something called the Delian
League. The Delian League is like NATO,
it's a defensive alliance. If the
Persians attack then this alliance will
um,
will defend together against the the
Persians.
Now, the Athenians had the best navy at
this time and the other islands are
like, you know, we don't have a navy.
But, what we'll do is this, we'll give
you our gold, okay? So, to all these
um, islands, they put all their wealth
on a place called Delos. This is why why
we have the Delian League name, okay?
And this money is meant as a mutual
defense fund.
You're not supposed to touch it
until unless the Persians invade, in
which case you use this money to uh
defend against the Persians, okay?
That's the idea.
And this worked out well until
the Athenians stole the money, right?
Um
Why? Because they wanted to create
something called the Parthenon.
Okay? Which is one of the most beautiful
buildings in the world.
And within the building is the statue of
Athena. It's pure gold. Okay? So,
the Athenians stole all this money from
Delos, from their allies,
and they built this Parthenon, and the
wealthy were able to steal from the
Parthenon in the construction process.
And so, the citizens of of of Athens
became really wealthy. It's easy money,
right? And remember,
easy money destroys a society.
And so, this is what led to the
Peloponnesian War because
after Athens stole this money,
it didn't it it didn't apologize to its
allies. In fact, it forced its allies to
continue to pay tribute to Athens.
Athens became a mafia state, okay? A
protection racket. If you don't give us
the money, then we'll come invade you.
And so, these allies started to
encourage Sparta to attack Athens, and
then that's what led to the
Peloponnesian War, okay? So, there are
three major incidents from the
Peloponnesian War that I want us to
focus on. The first incident is in 428
BCE. Um a place called Mytilene, um an
island.
They were a former
um Athenian ally who refused to pay
tribute. So, Athenians invaded and
conquered it. And now the question is,
what do you do now? How do you teach
these guys a lesson? How do you ensure
this doesn't happen again?
So, um one faction in Athens said,
"Let's kill all the men."
Okay? Pretty simple, right? Let's kill
all the men, and then we'll we'll um
spread fear among our allies, and no one
will rebel against anymore.
Um so, they have a have a debate, and
all of a sudden they say, "Let's kill
them all." So, they send a trireme, a
ship, to the island and to give the
orders to the Athenian soldiers to kill
everyone. Well, not everyone, but the
men and enslave the
women and the children, okay?
But after after the debate,
um the Athenians started to
talk amongst themselves, and a lot of
them couldn't sleep, and they're like,
"This is wrong. We're Athenians. We are
um We are a democrat We're We're a
democracy. We fight for freedom
and liberty. We can't do this to our
allies." So, the very next morning, the
Athenian citizens get together and says,
"We're going to have another debate, and
we're going to discuss what to do." And
so, they have this huge debate, and they
says, "No, we're Athenians. We're
virtuous. We will not do this." So, they
send another trireme
uh to catch up to the first trireme. And
remember, the first trireme is way
ahead, right? They They They have a
day's um
um um journey ahead. So, the other
trireme, they
work their their asses off to catch up
to the first trireme, and at the very
last minute they catch up, and they tell
the soldiers not to kill the men, okay?
And so, this is the clash between
democracy and empire,
right?
Now, let's fast forward um to um 416.
And now, another thing happens where
the Athenians are losing this war
against Sparta. It's costing them a lot
of money.
Um they're forced to melt down the
statue of Athena, the goddess, and use
the gold to pay for this
this war, okay?
And so,
um at And so, their attitude changes,
and now they're completely a mafia
state. They don't care about democracy,
don't care about virtue. All they want
is for their allies to pay tribute,
okay? So, they go invade an island
called Melos.
And Melos is not part of this war.
They're not part of Sparta. They're not
part of Athens. They're just neutral.
And then the Athenians said, "We don't
care. You pay tribute to us."
Okay? They're They're basically like a
mafia racket now. And the And the And
the And the Melian say, "We We We're
neutral.
Uh you have to respect our neutrality."
And the Athenians say in response,
"Right, as the world goes, it's only in
question between equals in power, while
the strong do what they can and the weak
suffer what they must." All right? So
So 12 years later, the Athenians are
like, "Screw virtue, screw democracy,
screw liberty, just give us money."
All right? So remember this idea.
Athenians wanted the trappings of
empire. They also want to feel virtuous.
And over time as Athens became more
poor, they're like, "Screw virtue, let's
have an empire." And that's why
Um in 415, Alcibiades, who who basically
is the Trump of Athens at this time,
okay? He says to Athenian people, "Hey
guys,
we're losing this war against Sparta,
but don't worry. Let's go invade more
territory."
Okay? So they decide to go invade
Sicily, which is very wealthy. The
problem though is that Sicily's pretty
far away, okay? Remember this is Athens
defending this huge war in the Aegean
Sea against the Spartans, and they're
going to go and invade Sicily for its
money, okay?
And it's pretty far away.
And it's not really well thought out.
They don't really think about how to
resupply the soldiers, and eventually
their expedition gets wiped out um
at
Syracuse, okay? So it's a disaster for
the Athenians, and it turns the war in
favor of the Spartans.
Um Athens is so bad that that everyone
gets together The entire world gets
together to destroy Athens. The
Persians, remember the Persians were the
enemies of both Sparta and Athens,
right? The Persians start to finance the
Spartans. And the Spartans eventually
laid siege to Athens and defeat the
Athenians, okay?
So,
why is this important? Well, because
history is history is going to repeat
itself, okay? There's There's going to
be a lot of similarities between the
Persian Peloponnesian War and and
American empire today. First similarity
is NATO. Remember, the Athenians had the
Delian League and
um
the Americans have NATO, okay? And NATO
always meant to be a defensive alliance.
But, if that's the case, then why is it
that
the Nord Stream pipeline got destroyed?
Remember, the Nord Stream pipeline, it
sends cheap gas from Russia to Germany.
The German economy is used cheap Russian
resources, primarily gas, uh
manufacturing the best cars in the world
and sell to China, okay? But, because of
this war in Ukraine, um America not only
limited um basically embargoed uh
Russian gas to Germany, which destroyed
the Russian economy, but some people
even say that the Americans destroyed
the pipeline,
okay? So, the Americans are attacking
their own allies.
Um
Trump has said that
America should take over Greenland and
Canada.
Why? Because they're wealthy, they have
lots of resources, and also they don't
have really strong militaries, right?
Trump he he he's he's like a mafia
godfather.
America is behaving like a mafia
system today.
Um
Now,
what America is doing is it's forcing
Europe to disarm itself. So, So, this is
Germany and Germany, Britain, France,
they've all announced these huge
military budgets. And so, you're like,
"Okay, does this mean that we'll have
World War III?"
Well,
America doesn't think like that. America
isn't like, you know, like, "Let's fight
Russia." America is like, "How can we
uh exploit our allies further, right?"
And so, you can make the argument that
this is not really about fighting the
Russians. It's really about getting
their allies, France, Germany, and
Britain to buy expensive and crappy
American weapons.
Remember the military-industrial
complex, right?
The entire point is not to fight the
Russians. The Russians are just a
pretext, an excuse. The real purpose is
to get the Europeans to buy expensive
American weapons.
It's really a shakedown, okay?
All right.
So,
um all around the world, there's
protests
about what's happening in the Middle
East,
right?
Uh these are huge protests protesting
what's happening in Gaza
today.
But, ultimately, it's not going to
matter, all right? Why? Because
America's an empire. It's a mafia state.
It needs to destroy Iran in order to
maintain
its power, okay? So,
Americans want the trappings of empire.
They also want to feel virtuous. That's
why there's conflict right now. Over
time, as America becomes poorer and
poorer and more and more desperate, this
virtue will go away and the raw, brutal
power of America will express itself
throughout the world.
Um and this will eventually lead to us
lead us to the final conflict.
The war between Iran and the United
States.
Um Iran has been has been has been
preparing for a long time, okay? Ever
since 1979.
Um
America's been pre- preparing for a long
time. This conflict is World War III.
I can't I cannot
um
overstate how brutal this conflict will
be. It will lead to fundamental changes
in the world. Our lives will never be
the same again.
Everything that we've known in the past
is now gone forever. And we have to
prepare for a new future.
So,
um
I leave you
with a message, okay?
I know that this class has been
depressing. You've been with me for a
year now. It's been very depressing,
okay? Because we've we've gone into the
heart of darkness of humanity.
Um and I know that the world looks more
and more terrible.
But, remember this, okay? And this is my
final message to you.
Remember this.
The greatest minds of humanity, which
include Homer,
Dante, Immanuel Kant. They've all told
us this. They've all told us one secret
of the universe. One message, which is
this.
The imagination is the animating
animating force of the universe.
Love is the unifying force of the
universe.
Okay? What this means is this. Which
What this means is that in the darkest
times, when all hope has been lost, when
there's only despair,
any of us, you, me, you, any one of us,
can rise up, stand up, and be the light
to lead humanity forward.
Okay? And that's the task ahead of us if
we are to save humanity in this darkest
of
times, okay? So, remember this. We all
have the capacity to imagine. We all
have the capacity to love. That's what
makes us human. In the worst times,
we must defend our own humanity.
Okay? So, that is it. Thank you so much.